>> DONNER: Welcome to Authors@Google. I'm
Marc Donner and I'm here to introduce Barbara
Probs Solomon. I've known Barbara many years
as a family friend and I've actually been
learning a little bit about her amazing career
and the time that we've been preparing for
this visit. As a teenager, shortly after the
end of World War II, Barbara did a rather
radical and sort of courageous thing and went
to Europe to look around and understand what
had happened there. At the time, when going
to Europe was not a luxurious trip to see
the sites and enjoy good food and live in
luxury. And there she got involved in the
struggle against the factious regime in Spain,
helping found a magazine called Peninsula
that was produced in Paris and smuggled across
the Pyrenees and to Spain and getting involved
in rescuing political prisoners from Spanish
prisons and all kinds of amazing experiences,
coming back and becoming a world famous writer
here in the U.S. And we're here to celebrate
this new edition of her literary magazine
Reading Room. What's particularly interesting
about Reading Room from a sort of a geek perspective
is that it represents an entirely new approach
to publishing in a way that isn't obvious.
Because when you look at, it looks just like
a fairly conventional collection of pieces
of dead tree bound together. But what's remarkable
is the production process doesn't involve
conventional publishing houses. The type setting
is done by the authors. And the book is printed
on demand by a service that they use. So no
longer is it the case that to get something
published, you have to commit a lot of capital,
print thousands of them and stick them in
a warehouse and then hope that they sell.
So, there's lots of very interesting things
that I think she can teach us. So, Barbara?
>> SOLOMON: Well, first of all, I do want
to thank Marc Donner and Nicky Bausch [ph]
and all of you who come here to be with me
and hear this, for coming and for giving your
support. I'll probably use a mixture in my
usual offhand way of what I've written, and
also, my offhand comments. And then later
on, there are books there. And as a visual,
it's always been very important to us. I am--this,
I'll leave with Google, but these are all
different issues. And as you can see, we are
literary but with a big interest also in the
way things look, which, by the way, has helped
us. And I just want to speak a little bit
first about various things. Mainstream Publishing,
which after all my adventures in Europe as
a young--I came back to America belatedly
enrolled in the School of General Studies
and set out to be a writer. And then, so I
want to discuss that and I want to discuss
the modern technology involved. And to the
end, and I want a segway into a mutual discussion
of some thoughts for the future because we're
always just a little peg in the moment of
time going towards the next step. They'll
be your next step may not be mine. I mean
maybe, but still everything is always in transition.
Okay. For a moment, you know, the great best
sellers of the 90th century, of course, were
Harriet Beecher Stowe, Uncle Tom's Cabin and
Dickens, which were good books, but which
had some kind of a moral point. And there
was a society out there ready to receive them.
And though--as Lincoln said, “Harriet Beecher
Stowe is a little lady who practically started
the Civil War." And sometimes, you have good
writing where writers are able to mesh their
talent, their ability to write with a social
temper of their times but not always. Just
take a quick look after a brief period of
recognition. Herman Melville was virtually
forgotten. Moby Dick was almost unknown until,
really he was reclaimed in the 1940s. F. Scott
Fitzgerald got off to a great start as the
bard of the Jazz Age. But then, his career
really ended abruptly in the crash, in the
Depression. He wasn't the writer for those
times. So it isn't just a question of ability
and talent. Then at a later point, of course,
we all know the Great Gatsby too. So it's
hard for us to imagine that when he died in
1940, he was a has-been sort of broke writer
trying to eke out a living in Hollywood and
nobody was thinking about the Great Gatsby.
So things come and go. Orwell sold 3,000 copies
of another classic when it was out here in
the early 50s; Homage to Catalonia, which
is now to it in probably every school. So,
it's a very up and down kind of road. Okay.
Marc gave that wonderful introduction and
we'll come back to him. But anyway, after
all of that, in my early--I'm about 22. I
don't know. But I came back to the United
States. I wanted to be a writer, although
my interest in Spain never stopped, went to
the School of General Studies to get belatedly
an undergraduate degree. And in one writing
workshop, I took one. We were explained the
dos and don'ts of how we writers would become
writers [INDISTINCT]. Now, one rule was that
you're only supposed to submit your story
magazine piece or novel to one magazine or
one publisher at a time. Now, I was stunned.
We knew that publisher sometimes kept managing
people for over a year. Sometimes magazines
didn't reply, and I, in my manner, said, "Well,
what kind of dumb rule is that? I mean, it's
sort of like signing a contract with someone
who didn't know you existed, whom you didn't
know existed and was under no obligation to
you. So right from the start, I shocked everybody
in the class and the teacher because I said
I was multiple submitting my work. I didn't
think it was unlikely to believe that anyone
or two people publish me for some bizarre
chance to publish one of my work. They would
probably want it more if they thought they
lost out to a competitor. Also, as I felt
that I was morally in the right, I was perfectly
willing to explain my reasoning in the unlikely
moment that a publisher would, two publishers
would want what I wrote. It never actually
happened. But I should--so I didn't have to
worry. But I always multiple submit it. Save
myself a lot of time, watched my friends.
It was incredible. They would let these books
languish at a publisher, gave them some bizarre
sense of security, I think. But I do want
to make clear that none of us are born like
Venus straight out of a seashell. We're all
influenced by our background. And I came from
the family of lawyers and law professors and
I had heard just enough legal eagle talk over
the dinner table. As an addition to being
a lawyer, by the way, my father was very successful
and innovative entrepreneur, to feel that
this publishing world was sitting on very
mushy terrain. And let me point out, my mother
also was an artist, so my later interest individuals.
So, you know, we all come from some place.
And usually, when we start our careers, we
deny it. Most Americans are not happy with
the way they're born. They think they're either
too poor, too middle-class, too rich, too
regular, too irregular. We never suited. But
anyway, we all come from somewhere. Among--and
I want to discuss this because I think it's
important even for Google to think about this.
Among the other deadly sins, we, presumably
fledgling writers, were warned against, were
vanity publishers. Although, the concept of
vanity publishing is not really in the minds
of your generation of entrepreneurial web
technology use, I think it's interesting to
look at its history a bit because I do think
it held back writers, that had an almost phobic
fear of vanity publishing and confusion about
what the term meant. And this interest me
because I've been interested as to why my
group, i.e., writers as distinguished from
artist and other people have been so up until
your generation, backward about pushing themselves
forward. Group theater productions have always
existed. Hollywood script writers, they had
tough unions. I lives also a bit in the art
word and artists, certainly in the last 50
years, were not hesitant to get what they
wanted or to create the kinds of art galleries
that would represent their kind of work. And
interestingly enough, artists define themselves
and their success by the sale of their work
as we know, preparedly, for very high prices.
In those words, and those are such expressions
as you [INDISTINCT], which really basically
meant no sales. But in the literally world
where big sales were confused with best sellers
for a long time, it was very mushy. And although,
it's true what we were told, the vanity publishers
to beware of them, they were fly-by-night
businesses that took the money of unsuspecting
writers, promising kind of weird results.
But what has to be straightened out is that
vanity publishing, which was sort of one of
many minor, very minor bad little things,
should not be confused with the almost inexplicable
passivity of writers. These are two different
things; at least, literary writers. So I think
we should dust it off and make clear the difference
between sleazy vanity publishing and the need
for writers as do all other artist to use
their own initiative. These are two different
things, because curiously enough, literary
writers--I'm sorry, have been--I thought they
were very passive. Now, I became lucky, my
editor, Ferneley, all my books was Cork Smith,
one of the great publishing editors. And it's
true; my books were published in first-rate
houses eventually. But nonetheless, I was
always sticking my nose in, whether it was
your--I was making sure that the photograph
I selected looked more the way I wanted to
project myself rather than the way I actually
looked or by tramping to double days on Fifth
Ave. and other major bookstores with my book
under my arm, I would say, "The publicity
apartment says, 'To contact your local bookstore.'”
I think they were thinking of small town bookstore.
I would say, “Well, I'm in Manhattan, this
is my local place. Would you put it in the
window?” They were sort of surprised, but
they usually did. In other words, it's a cliché.
Nothing ventured. Nothing gained. But this
is not the way literary writers thought. They
wanted to feel they were being taken care
of. And as I once said in Spain a remark much
quoted: "In reality, there are no prestige
publishing houses. There are prestige writers
who lend publishing houses their prestige.
And let us be aware of two different things."
But by the 1980s, publishing which had started
out sort of a gentlemen's cottage industry,
with its goods and defects, it was essentially
over, the conglomerates had taken over. Publishers
needed to show Wall Street returns. Cork and
I had talked it over, and interestingly, any
editor or writer who is not a total retard
had to understand at least the quarter of
century ago, that big time publishers now
had an infrastructure which only as a minor
sideline could include literary works. It
was too unwieldy for this mammoth structure
that was sort of an MGM structure. And then
by 1986, when I covered the trial of the Nazi
work criminal Klaus Barbie Leon for American
publication and for the Spanish--it was sort
of like Time Magazine, Cambio 16, I was then
on their staff, one of their correspondents.
I began to think about technology. By then,
I had my first computer, but to Leon, I was
able to take a little tiny portable brother
which was like, “Oh, that's way to being
a computer.” It was like a mini kind of--I
mean, we look it now and we'd laugh. But it
did print and you could attach it to a portable
printer. A little mini thing that, again,
we would laugh at. And I now could get my
pieces almost instantly from Leon, to Cambio
in Madrid or America overnight. As a journalist,
I thought, "Wow! I mean, this little dinky
thing, it would--it could print like four
pages at a time." I mean, it had that kind
of capacity to hold maybe four, six pages
or eight. Enough for an article, you know.
And I began to see the world was beginning--because
I do a lot of journalism to change then in--I
think it was 2001. A friend of mine, literary
agent Eugene Winnick [ph] because he knew
I was always nattering on him about the need
for little magazines, etcetera, etcetera.
He said, "Come with me to this Expo in Chicago."
What I saw in Chicago was a demonstration
of Lightning's print on demand. A book was
put on one machine. It seems to be carried
through a conveyor belt to a series of machines
that to me, looked like laundry machines.
But anyway, that would pop a book. Suddenly,
when I read all the brochures and the demonstrators
who took us around, and I began to sense what
they were doing. It flashed through my mind
that this might be a possible for me to achieve
my long time dream of having my own literary
magazine. At this point, I have to confess
something. My best subject, even though as
a writer, was always mathematics. So I heard
my father's voice, the great entrepreneur,
he was successful, advising me, "Don't worry
about little luxuries, they can always be
stopped; just keep the basic net down, the
basic nut down.” I looked at these brochures.
There would be no warehouse cost, no middle
man, the setup charges were minimal. If I
hire a good designer and art was important
to me, I realize that the book and the print
type could look good. The books would go from
Lightning to Ingram distributors directly
to online bookstores like Amazon and Barnes
and Noble. You could also--if you got them
into independent bookstores, they could be
there, and basically, you know, no warehouse,
no returns. And Ginny Winco [ph] but then
at Lightning told me that Jason Eipstein of
Random House and I were the first people in
the literary publishing world to realize the
potential, not of other things but of print
on demand. Jason was thinking books, but my
mind was going into another direction. A literary
magazine that look like a magazine by that
time would have cost a fortune. And I could
give some time, but I really couldn't afford
to lose money despite my so-called dazzling
career. My husband had died young. I had to
raise two daughters, one of them Marc knows,
and that's my granddaughter, Catherine is
over there. I had a family to support and
I managed but I didn't have at that point
in my life having, kind of raise my kids alone.
I didn't, as a writer, have the kind of money
that would have permitted me to lose money.
I could give my time, but I couldn't lose
money. And anyway, I said to myself, “Distribution
is already shaky. Stories are carried.”
Literary magazines were already going out
of business. So I thought what's to prevent
me from making a literary magazine in a book
form, one that could go easily into online,
Barnes and Noble, et cetera, et cetera. If
they were to be no returns and no this and
no that, and many of them goes, “There was
basically no downside.” And I think at this
point, different parts of my personality meshed.
In my freshman year in high school, I was
the only girl who was chosen to work in the
print-liner type machine. My mother really
was a first-rate artist. And then, of course,
it was my informative experience in Europe
which Marc has already covered. But still,
the fact that we were able to smuggle magazines,
cross borders, et cetera, et cetera, was on
my mind when I made the Reading Room and I
also saw--knew how one little magazine made
in cold, water rooms in Paris ended up being
part of Spanish history in a much, much, much
later date. And so, Marc has discussed my
life in Europe, so I'm not really going to
go so much into that here now even though
you can question me more about it.
>> Hello. So, I have a question. I was wondering
if you could talk a little bit more about
what it was like to go to Europe in 1948 and
really, was it for you the kind of mentality
that you seem to have in the beginning of
your literary career of nothing ventured,
nothing gained. I mean, what was your real
inspiration to do that?
>> SOLOMON: Oh, it's a good question. And
I think there are variety of explanations.
One, I think as a child, I was interested
in Europe. My father had been--a private in
the trenches, gassed in the first World War.
And I always thought, "Oh, it wasn't for certain
bullet going the wrong way, I might not have
existed." Okay. So that was one reference.
My mother was an artist. The truth of the
matter is some of my independence came from
the fact that she frequently abandoned the
family and she, in the '30s at times to World
War II, we take off for Europe, generally
for London. And then I had a nanny who was
from Germany. And as a Jewish child even though
the nanny came over here well before Hitler,
it created also two things. So various things;
one, the fact that through--I was always wondering
what drew these people to Europe. Now my father,
he was drafted. Another--so, my--I had to
fix on that. And then, you know, I learned
to watch from the movies like every generation.
When I was in the high school, the movies,
if you ever look, Turner classic movies, were
all about World War II. So this was no exoteric
subject. In fact, I'm ashamed to say it looked
rather glamorous, you know, so all these things.
And then I had I think a natural inclination
too, even though I was curious because I was
a good student. But I don't think I was so
school-oriented, you know. I mean, when I
was little, I had read about Thomas Wolf.
The first Thomas Wolf who was then a great
writer from the South convinced my parents,
therefore, to--he was dead, to let me go to
a work camp, which is what they were called
then. They were cheaper. In North Carolina,
in the Appalachians, in the region where they
shot, now, Cold Mountain a few years ago,
so I was sort of wanting to see what the [INDISTINCT]
or it wasn't the [INDISTINCT], the equivalent
look like. And I was then about, I don't know,
ten or eleven. So I think, combined with things
in the popular culture, which were the movies,
if it wasn't some great history book, the
movies--the women in my family, my father's
early experiences as a private and my natural
of inclination to--there are many kinds of
writers. I would never be a great player.
I'm never going to be a great poet. I don't
even think I was very good short-story writer.
I was good at writing what I saw, you know.
So these things, does that answer your question
a bit?
>> So we started to talk about a topic that
I'm very curious about. So I'll sort of put
it out here for further comments. I studied
Spanish in high school, and I was sort of
got advanced enough to be introduced to some
Spanish literature. The thing that I find
remarkable about Spanish Literature versus
almost any other language with a major body
of literature is that it's largely unknown
in the English speaking world compared to
Russian or French or Italian or German where
tremendous amounts of that literature is translated
and sort of known, sort of by people who are
not in fact literati. Why is that?
>> SOLOMON: You're perfectly right. And what
we learned as students in school essentially
was not European history. We learned English
history with a touch of French thrown in and
it is curious because Spanish is one of the
great literatures. But aside from that, it
was also until we took Cuba back from them
the Philippines which--I mean, we also took
Spanish characters. I'm sure there's a lot
of that mixed into it. But it was the Holy
Roman Empire. It had more command over the
world than England did. And so, I know that
when I got back from Europe and went to college,
I was always translating in my mind. I thought
what they're teaching me is English history.
There's no Don Quixote. There's no--you would
never know, even to this day. You would not
know, because I was listening to the talk
about on the fourth of July, the American
Revolution. We know the French helped out.
You would never know that more money came
from the Spanish and they helped out. I mean,
for the wrong reasons, they had--first of
all, they had pacts with the French and they
were zany British as the French were. So they
saw it as a great investment. Now, would any--I'm
listening to these programs and I think, “Hey,
even though I reviewed books on this for the
Wall Street Journal about a year ago. What
do we know about or--and apparently, and this
is according to Hugh Thomas, who's a British,
not a Spaniard. Apparently, America still--and
Benjamin Franklin still always paid a pot
of money. I mean, so your question is well
taken, and then I think it was basically--I
don't know. We had England and France on our
minds basically. And then we were always at
war with something Spanish; later on, not
then. But--and in a way, it is curious because
this new issue of The Reading Room which you
can see over there which is--has really the--I
said the iconic figure. It's really the great
Spanish geniuses of contemporary Spanish literature
over the last 50 years. Well, it's actually
the first time they have been collected in
one volume. And we know we get a lot of support
for this issue. But the thing is again, it's
not normal that these world famous writers
are so unknown in this country. And I'll go
further and say, “One reason that we were
so startled by the so-called Spanish miracle
recovery after Franco is that we didn't have
a clue as to the huge investments and modernization
that Spain already had done, you know, which
is we didn't know.
>> I have two questions. One, with the--we
follow the new technology and internet. It's
going to become easier and easier to first
present your work. If you are a writer, all
you need to do is put it on the website. But
also as you mentioned, it's going to become
easier and easier to actually create your
own magazine because you don't need to select
the couple of...
>> SOLOMON: I don't get the last sentence.
What?
>> I'm saying, because it's also going to
become easier to create your own magazine,
dictionary magazine when you put it online.
>> SOLOMON: Yes.
>> You would also, I would also expect that
there's going to appear more and more of--say
junky magazine. So how do you view the pros
of selection of quality, content in the future?
>> SOLOMON: Okay. It depends from which point
of view do you mean from the reader, the buyer,
or the editor, which?
>> Well, I mean, if I'm a reader and suppose
there is a lot of magazines out there, how
would I actually know which one?
>> SOLOMON: It's good question and it's sort
of a dilemma. And it's not totally easy to
answer. I would still say--because one of
the ways that people use to select what they
wanted to read or what they felt was good
was through book reviewing. They could read
the reviews. Now, that is so closing down.
In fact, I was surprise to hear [INDISTINCT]
house of the Times Book Review to refer to
what he does in the Book Review and he said,
“And we include some literary fiction.”
They didn't use to be such a word because
The Times didn’t do just a little bit. And
if they did fiction, it was literary fiction.
So I think that--that kind of information
as to what you read, it goes to many channels.
It goes through universities. In other words,
it depends what your world is. Even with all
the technology, you're going to have to--the
down side, is that--which I think is really
what you're asking is that there's a lot of
junk on there. And how do you avoid the junk
and get to the good? And I think then you
get to know like there's a certain webpage
is [INDISTINCT] is one run by Steve Wasserman.
That has--have good reviewing sections that
you can believe in. And I think through--actually,
the way it was always done through your friends,
through school, through asking around through
some better--whenever the good literary review
things are. You get to know the--for example,
there's a good Jewish reviewing section. There
are things for other languages. But I think
that it's something that you and your generation
kind of have to figure out. I mean, in my
generation we said, “Hey, why don't you
read the New Republic?" or "Why don't read
you this?" or "Have you heard of this book?”
But I think there's a downside which is where
your problem will be is somehow working your
way and learning what not to go near, the
slush pile of the web. And I think there are
even webpages that address that issue, but
you have to be a bit of a detective.
>> And the second question is how do you feel
about the new electronic book reading devices
now like Amazon's Kindle or Sony Reader, do
you feel that they will replace the written--the
printed content?
>> SOLOMON: You know, I think that they are
good. I think it's--rather than seeing a particular
piece of technology as the answer, just the
way I see the Reading Room as--I see it as
one chink, one stage. And I mean, we have
digit or books that are digitalized. Hopefully,
at one point, they'll go on Kindle or some
other book form, you know, they are digitalized.
But I think that just like the computer didn't
stay--in the mini-computer I had in Leon in
1986. I think it's bad to think of anything
as fixed. Nothing is fixed; everything is
in transition. So it may be that--and by the
way, you should be--when uses more than one
technique at a time like the Reading Room
has the old fashion ideals of Little Magazines
which, by the by, something like 80 or 90%
of America's greatest writings including Ulysses
and [INDISTINCT] came out of Little Magazines
not out of that big ball publishing. It's
import--80 or 90% of what we think are today's
classic or great writers, which is astonishing.
So these were little mom and pop things. Many
of them run by women. So, we use a combination
of old fashion techniques. In other words,
when I want outreach--oh, I mean, one of the
assets, I would say, that I have is being
a kind of well-known writer. I have friends
and we can have events and so forth and so
on. So that's an old fashion technique. But
it's never going to stop with either print
on demand or Kindle books or whatever they
are. At this stage it's--you're better off
in taking the best of the past and always
thinking, “Hey, this isn't forever. This
is one step along the way.”
>> I was wondering what it was like to be
a woman in Spain in the later part of the
1940s, you know, Spain is in some ways for
good and bad known for it's sort of machismo
culture, and I was wondering if you faced
more opposition than you anticipated as an
independent woman there or if you expected
to receive more than you did?
>> SOLOMON: Okay. The short answer is that
women do well in wars and resistance movements
when there's nobody else around because they're
needed. And I was living in Paris and these
Spaniards were living in Paris, which was
a better place to be as a woman than the United
Sates at that time. Now, this was a sort of
extraordinary little group. I would have to
say--but again, the circumstances were different.
Everybody was sort of down and out and struggling.
And though, my remark to you maybe flipped
about women do well when needed. Nobody was
looking at Spain even later on. And I used
to tell my students, I said, "It's good to
know some stuff later on." When I was a writer
back in New York, the fact that I actually
new something, like the resistance movements
in Europe, help me get into American magazines
that would very machismo-like. The New Republic,
the New York Review of Books, which by the
way, in many ways I found far more prejudice
against Europe women than the myths of Europe.
In other words, if you--even today with major
American political women as figures, if you
look at the New York review, when you look
at the New Republic even the New Yorker, you
will usually find three women to 25 men. So,
I don't care what you call it. It's nuts.
>> You spoke a little bit about the conception
of the Reading Room. Can you talk a little
bit more about how you choose a topic, for
instance, or how you choose writers and the
pieces that go into it?
>> SOLOMON: Yes. That is--first of all, it's--this
was a question asked to me by friends when
I made--they said, “You'll never find writers
and agents.” They didn't seem to even in
2002. I understand that was not going to be
our problem. They were out of it. The publishing
world, excuse me, was totally out of sync
with anything that was going on. How do you
find writers? Well, first of all, a lot just
came to us. Remember...
>> How do you pick pieces...?
>> SOLOMON: Okay. I'm going to tell you. And
then I was professor. I had been at the city,
I had been at Sarah Lawrence. Some of our
interns and some of the writing pieces came
directly from there. We were all--it's not
just us, any magazine. It's more deluged than
not, you know. And our things were always
a mixture of super unknown mixed with Nobel
Prize winners. We had a big issue on Kenya.
This is long before Obama. And I'd say we
were idiosyncratic. And--but from the writer's
point of view--it sounds odd, but you're asking--are
you asking this from the writer's point of
view? Or the editors, which...
>> I guess more--I think it's more from the
editor's point of view. I mean, as a writer...
>> SOLOMON: Yes.
>> You know, if I would get something to you,
you would look at it and--on one criteria
or how do you decide then how to put together
one of these specifics?
>> SOLOMON: Okay. Well, usually what happens
is that in the beginning of each issue, we
usually have some things and then depending
on what writers are coming our way that we
think are good. Interestingly enough, even
though it looks--the finish product looks
as if we have carefully designated categories
and one leads into another, nothing like that
ever takes place. The categories come after
we have enough material that we think works
together and I would say there's this--it
comes in through my editors, it comes in through
me, it comes in through the trans of--it's
a mixture. But it is totally idiosyncratic
so that suddenly, you have all these things.
Now, this issue we knew we were going to make
Spanish, although it's blended with American
things. And suddenly I say, “Well, we don't
have something humorous or there's not enough
art, or we need some more essays and there's
enough poetry.” So it's kind of--I would
say in the long run, every book--and this
could be for mainstream or this sort of thing,
really represents the passions of the editor
and the taste. There's no right or wrong.
Magazines usually take on the identity and
the taste of the people who are running them
and making it, which is logical.
>> Well, we thank you so much for coming today.
>> SOLOMON: And thank you.
>> And we thank all of you for coming today
too. If you'd like to have your book signed,
please do that. And thank you so much.
>> SOLOMON: My pleasure. Goodbye.